et je pense que demain elle compte les
heures après huit mois de cours à
distance la coach céline pourra recevoir
un nouveau des sportifs dans sa salle de
montigny le bretonneux à partir de ce
mercredi 9 juin
je vais avoir peut-être ce n'est pas un
cours zoom par jour versus 5 à 6 heures
par jour et puis je re bascule de
l'autre côté au jour et cinq à six
heures de cours ici dans cette salle qui
a besoin de ressentir à nouveau palace
heures forcément parce que nous on
transpire pas beaucoup en yoga pilates
mais les bonnes ondes se retournant
cette salle de 80 mètres carrés sera
accompagné d'un protocole sanitaire
je ne mettrai jamais plus de cinq
personnes
parce que je veux que chacun se sente en
sécurité je des j'arrêterai tout les
cours cinq minutes vraiment avant la fin
pour que chacun ait le temps de
désinfecter à la lotion hydroalcoolique
son espace
même s'il vient avec son tapis et qu'il
est temps de sortir et que le groupe
suivant et le temps d'entrer sans que ça
se croisent à l'intérieur du studio dans
cette salle de sport à guyancourt les
gérants sont également prêts à
accueillir leurs mille adhérents pour
cela un dispositif stricte semblable au
premier déconfinement sera également mis
en place le gel à disposition mais
attendu à l'entrée du club désinfecter
son matériel avant et après
l'utilisation les serviettes lady
sensation de 10 mètres carrés par
adhérent
il va y avoir une jauge de 50 %
d'adhérents donc pour nous pour nous ce
sera à peu près 70 personnes en même
temps
ben club les douches individuelles donc
ils vont être condamnés une sur deux les
cases et de la même façon la principale
nouveauté sera la mise en place d'un qr
code a flashé à son arrivée dans la
salle pour accéder à un cahier de rappel
numérique
il suffit de télécharger l'application
anti covin signal et de cliquer sur le
scan qr code sur son téléphone et il
suffira juste de se caler ce petit qr
codes là en 30 secondes et ça montrera
son passage dans la salle à telle heure
tel jour tu es celle de sport espère
maintenant que ce dispositif permettra
de relancer la machine et surtout
inciter les sportifs à s'inscrire à la
rentrée prochaine un moment clé pour le
secteur